now of course tonight we are in
beautiful South Carolina to interview
the man who wants challenge the corrupt
Biden family born in 1965 in North
Charleston uh Senator Tim Scotty grow
poor in a single-parent household his
wonderful mom is here in the audience
with us tonight
um
he nearly flunked out of school before
turning his life around graduating from
high school graduating from college and
starting a successful business
ultimately becoming one of the great
senators from the great state of South
Carolina embodying the American dream in
every way imaginable but according to
Democrats and the media mob and the
women of the view
[Applause]
I love South Carolina I do
Senator Scott is a bad person who just
doesn't understand what it's like to be
an African-American
take a look and he's one of these guys
who you know he's like Clarence Thomas
black Republican who believes in pulling
himself by your bootstraps rather than
to me understanding the systemic racism
that African Americans face in this
country and other minorities he doesn't
get it neither does uh Clarence right
and that's why they're Republicans Tim
Scott standing there to provide the
patina of diversity over that uh round
of words at basket full of words I
haven't spent a lot of time studying Tim
Scott's speeches I think there is a long
history of African-American or other
minority candidates within the
Republican Party who will validate
Americans say everything's great
and we can all make it
wow nothing like getting
nothing like a lecture to an
African-American man about what it's
like to be black in America from a white
liberal from New York right
now in reality in reality they just
don't like what Senator Scott represents
Democrats rely on the politics of
victimhood identity politics but Tim
Scott is no victim he is a poised leader
he works hard makes good decision forges
his own path to success
let's give a warm South Carolina Welcome
to the man that would like to be the
next president of the United States
South Carolina Senator Tim Scott
uh
[Applause]
whoa
he threw it over it went it went over
the right we'll get you some more grab a
seat let me say this
let me just ask the crowd
how many of y'all are proud to be
Americans
we live in the freest fairest land on
God's green earth
and we will never apologize we will
never apologize for being Americans
[Applause]
you can keep stowing if you want I don't
yeah I'll just sit here and get paid
listen now I was just I love you Bella
love you back here listen I I was
listening to The View
[Applause]
when I went on when I went on The View
and said your comments are offensive
disgusting and dangerous because I want
Americans to understand what I
understand we get to climb as high as we
want to go as long as we're going to
work for it your character your grit
your integrity takes a high in America
as high as you're willing to go
and for folks to lecture me on being
black
I I think that's pretty rich for Joy
behind lecture me for being black
someone who gets away with wearing black
face
can you imagine if that was a
conservative
no or republican no on the errors of
this nation no that would never last
there's a double standard in this
country and that's why we've got us our
winning elections I agree with that too
we've got to start winning the elections
again
and I'll tell you
[Applause]
I thank God that I was raised by a mama
who understood that sometimes love comes
at the end of a switch
[Applause]
and I gotta say my mama love me a lot
I'm getting fired up here Thomas
did you use a switch on them a bunch
oh yeah we got a shot of that I want to
say yeah she's a child please that was
great well great to see you as well uh I
guess first I got to get your reaction
to the news of the day you know we um
sad to say I don't believe right now in
America that we have equal justice under
the law or equal application of our laws
we know that they've had this case
before plus years we know about that
1023 form I'd like to know what
investigation they've done we know about
all this money Hunter Biden with no
experience made we know Joe Biden
bragged about leveraging a billion
dollars to keep his son in in the money
with Barista Holdings nothing happened
to him absolutely I worry if we don't
have equal justice Senator it's
dangerous let me just say we all know
this that the big guy has some
explaining to do without a question
Sean
we cannot be the city on the hill if we
are not first a nation of Law and
Justice we can't be the city on the hill
we cannot fulfill our destination our
destiny as America if we do not have the
lady of Justice wearing a blindfold
we all have to be treated equally under
the eyes and the laws of our country
and when the bidens get away with that
we need to thank God for Senator
Grassley and Congressman Coomer for
doing their jobs but I can tell you
[Applause]
if they can't finish their investigation
president Tim Scott will finish it
we're gonna
with your help we're gonna we're gonna
fire Joe Biden
and then we're gonna we're gonna fire
mayor Garland
[Applause]
and fire Christopher Ray
and we're going to restore we're going
to restore confidence Integrity in our
department of justice we can't have them
going after the pro-life activists with
a SWAT team
you can't call parents who show up at a
school board meeting domestic terrorist
and you cannot it is unacceptable and
Un-American to weaponize the Department
of Justice against your political
opponents it's just wrong
we're just getting warmed up things are
getting started we're in beautiful
Myrtle Beach South Carolina Senator Tim
Scott with us for the rest of the hour
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else